regardez cette vidéo qui a fait
énormément parler cette mère de famille
qui s'est plainte au président de la
république du manque de mixité dans les
banlieues et elle a pris un exemple qui
a fait énormément parler aujourd'hui
regardez je déplore le manque de mixité
dans le collège de mortier les gens ne
mettent plus les enfants dans le même
quartier et ce qui est vraiment dommage
je suis président j'ai mon fils qui a 8
ans il m'a demandé si pied le prénom de
pia existait vraiment c'est que dans le
livre ont tellement qu'il ya manque de
mixité dans le quartier c'est vraiment
grave quoi je lui dis non au fils pierre
existe vraiment il ya des gens qui
s'appellent pierre
moi je fais sortir mes enfants mais
c'est vrai que cette question m'a alors
et c'est vrai que ça fait énormément
parler aujourd'hui comprenez vous que
leurs proches qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
blancs à discorde il est avec nous
mercialys d'être avec nous vous avez
vous décaler un peu parce qu'alice est
dans le noir donc merci brute lucson de
flux' merci d'être là comment ça va sa
rivale a très bien géré ailleurs très
bon jour de rachid qui tombera ce jour h
et donnant le sens ça bouge pas c'est
bien david guiraud raccords de la france
a souvent merci david qui vient souvent
du bois et guillaume bigot
éditorialistes qui viennent nous voir
aussi souvent alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde n'a parlé
que de ça cette histoire a suscité de
très nombreuses réactions de la place
que la classe politique à commencer par
le gouvernement chez pascal praud ce
matin emmanuelle wargon la ministre du
logement directement concernés par le
sujet expliqué que les gens avaient
besoin de mixité regarder la prise de
parole de cette femme très forte hier
c'est bien la demande de mixité la
demande de mixité de la part de
populations pour lesquelles on pense
qu'on a une forme de préjugé pensant que
chacun va rester entre soi et en fait
c'est pas vrai et moi je me déplace
beaucoup dans des quartiers populaires
en ville dans la ruralité et les gens en
fait sont en demande de cette mixité
sociale est ce que cette femme dit c'est
une demande de mixité sociale de mixité
culturelle
alors y'a ministre de l'intérieur aussi
gérald darmanin qui a réagi là-dessus
regarder la dame qui témoignent les
témoignes pour deux raisons je trouve
que c'est très juste qu'elle et ses
dames d'abord c'est une femme comme vous
l'avez dit qu'ils étaient voilées kamel
foulard et celle qui demandait la mixité
sociale celle qui remercie les forces de
police de lutter contre les stupéfiants
celle qui s'attaquait aux barbus elle
l'a dit elle même vous avez passé qu'un
extrait
à bord moi j'ai confiance dans la
république lorsque neil mac est né au
maroc elle l'a dit elle même elle y est
arrivée à l'âge de 7 ans en france dit
moi je veux la mixité sociale dans mon
quartier je veux des polynésiens la fin
je veux lutter quand il s'amuse bien sûr
c'est pour ça que dans le quartier
derrière le maire de montpellier
je ne suis pas vous dire est que hier
indépendamment lutter contre le trafic
de stupéfiants
nous refaisons tout dans ce quartier et
notamment on évite de faire 90 % de
logements sociaux dans un immeuble ça ne
peut pas marcher
alors tout le monde a ragé on a d'autres
réactions gilles verdez pour vous c'est
oui vous comprenez qu'on reproche qui
n'est pas assez blanc dans les banlieues
bien sûr il faut des pierres dans les
banlieues et il faut aussi des
souleymane dans les villes blanches qui
refusent des logements sociaux qui
refusent d'intégrer les noirs et les
arabes parce que ça existe et la france
va mourir de cette absence de mixité
cette dame a raison si on n'agit pas ça
va être une france qui va exploser car
une frange coupée en deux alors gérald
ils mettent pas d'accord non en fait il
faut il faut il faut il faut ok il faut
mais sauf que ça fait 40 ans qu'on dit
qu'il faut mais ça c'est bon on ne fait
pas donc les territoires perdus de la
république mal
valls avait parlé même d'un apartheid
social on était tous tombés dessus
donc malgré tout il ya aujourd'hui une
sorte de discrimination
les gens sont partis il ya une
ghettoïsation c'est une réalité donc
cette femme c'est fort et fait
effectivement sa prise de parole parce
qu'elle est voilée est donc en fait elle
sert d'exemple parce que tout d'un coup
on se dit oh la la c'est une femme
voilée qui dit ça car c'est une femme
qui demande la mixité qui demande le
brassage qui demande qu'on soit pas de
discriminer qu'on est pas que les gens
parquet d'un côté et les blancs de
l'autre en gros et les noirs et les
musulmans de l'autre côté
donc oui c'est fort mais en fait le
problème c'est qu'on ne décrète pas je
ne sais pas si les gens veulent vivre
ensemble en fait je ne sais pas je pense
que c est nous logique je pense que les
gens sont heureux ce commentaire les
gens qui se ressemblent envie d'être
ensemble c'est incroyable pierre le
hashtag pierre aujourd'hui et été on
détecte toute la journée salle d'op
tweet c'est fou stevie vous dites waouh
on se trouve ça incroyable cette
histoire moi j'ai bien sûr qu'il faut de
la mixité
enfin ça sont peu plus entasser les gens
comme ça dans les banlieues et les
banlieues pour moi foulée rasé et tout
refaire repartir à zéro et leur donner
accès à la propriété
mimi la première chemise parce que quand
on est chez soi et que son bien enfin en
a sont bien des gens ont fait beaucoup
plus attention et ça se passe plutôt
bien
il ya eu des bulles où ça s'est passé ça
s'est très très bien passé se met ce
brassage moi je suis pas content je suis
pas pour ces ghettos je ne trouve pas ça
bien du tout
alors je mets oui mais je pourrais
maintenant en fait le problème il est
pas là c est ce que pierre a envie
d'aller habiter dans ces quartiers là
mais non aussi bien que ceux qui y
vivent ils ont pas envie de rester dans
ces ghettos
parce que il ya certains immeubles se
sont devenus mes mais ces cdd pourriture
certains immeubles sacré des quartiers
pourris ça crée une ambiance terrible et
ça laisse du coup la place ba ont
trafiqué autres et autres tracy le
problème c'est que ça date depuis très
longtemps
la fameuse vague d'immigrés qui est
arrivé dans les années 80 tout ça génial
ça super machin sauf qu'on leur a donné
que des devoirs et aucun droit on leur a
dit et moi j'en ai vu des campagnes
s'assoit législatives ou et les
kouroussa notariale ou peu importe il
trace les néo les contours de la ville
et il dit ces quartiers on va pas y
aller mais pourquoi on va pas les faire
campagne là bas parce qu'ils votent pas
il veut passer des immigrés dont qui
votent pas on va parler s'emmerder aller
voir ce qui se passe dans ces quartiers
là et à force de créer ce cheminement
les mômes qui sont nés ici donc les mots
de ces immigrés ils sont nés en france
ils ont vu leurs parents travailler mais
comme et comme des acharnés parfois
cumulé deux trois boulots pour payer des
impôts en france mais on leur a dit ta
loi payer des impôts en france mais en
revanche n'a rien droit dire on ferme là
tu marches tu perds et tu te tais alors
ça crée une génération de révolter et à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des émeutes
on comprend 2005 sous de villepin il ya
une émeute qui fini heureusement pas un
moment donné parce que ça peut aller en
guerre civile alors à discorde est
présidente et fondatrice de nemesis
groupe féministe identité pour vous
quand on dit que qui ont quand on
reproche qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
blancs dans les banlieues où vous dites
quoi bah écoutez moi je suis d'accord
avec quasiment personne autour de ce
plateau sauf que géraldine savary
et en effet je pense que cela parlait il
ya un certain nombre de personnes aussi
qu'ils ne veulent pas habiter dans ces
banlieues là pourquoi pas ce qui
n'incite insécurité qui accroît moi je
suis responsable d'un collectif ce n'est
une féministe au collectif nemesis donc
et on a tous les jours dans ce
témoignage
tous les jours on reçoit des témoignages
de femmes qui me disent mais nous en
fait on n'en peut plus on habite là-bas
il ya du harcèlement on est toujours
embêté par la même sorte de personne et
nous on l'a vu aussi 500 personnes
vous voulez dire course et des personnes
généralement issus des migrations c'est
vrai que 63% dans l'est dans les
transports en commun d'agression sont
par des personnes étrangères
donc j'ai quand même un problème et je
pense qu'il ya un problème s'il fallait
pas besoin du ministère de l'intérieur
je crois pas qu'ils soient réglés et
donc anticiper le ministère de
l'intérieur n'était pas libre à vous est
venu donc du coup merci alors s'il vous
plaît aux on laisse parler là oui bah
oui alors j'ouvre des sections et plus
le constat est le même temps à des
femmes qui sont désespérés qu'ils disent
mais merci d'intervenir merci aussi de
nous dire qu'ils agressent vraiment
aussi dans les transports en commun mais
dans l'espace public parce qu'il ya une
réalité à ce niveau là que certains ne
veulent pas voir vous parler monsieur du
fait qu' on les a mis de côté dans les
sites etc
mais on a mis énormément d'argent aussi
dans les cités on est on en a mis
énormément
tous les jours on en mai et il n'y a pas
ça n'évolue pas non plus il y avait
beaucoup de riverains qui n'en peuvent
plus de cette situation là la jeune
femme à qui en parler la mère de famille
n'en peut plus et ça se voit donc il
faut lutter contre cela et je pense
qu'il faut aussi avoir de pardon alors
de l'insécurité et de la sécurité de son
quartier sur la sécurité d'insécurité
son quartier alors elle elle elle
mettait en avant le fait que les blancs
apparemment puisque armes on a appris
depuis le début qu'il ya padres mme
apparemment les blancs maintenant servir
la mode on avait pris depuis le début
qu'ils n'avaient pas il y en a pas
apparemment dans son quartier mais ça
explique aussi le dernier pierre qu'on a
vue qui habitait en cité il a fini il
avait 68 ans il a fini la tête décapitée
par des jeunes aussi donc au bout d'un
an faut comprendre ici tout cela on
arrive à licha lice avec nemesis
connaître la date des happenings coup de
poing en janvier vous avez vous voulu
montrer ce que serait la femme française
dans 50 ans regardez ces images très
très polémique
voilà c'est le groupe nemesis voilà
d'alice les sens de notre action
aujourd'hui était de dénoncer le hidjab
dès qu'il ya un concept international
qui vise à se voiler en soutien aux
femmes musulmanes se serait martyrisé en
france et en europe
aujourd'hui nous nous préférons rendre
hommage aux femmes qui essayait
d'enlever leurs vols notamment dans les
pays du moyen-orient et du maghreb en
montrant qu'on pensait être se voit le
site peut arriver et que c'est une
catastrophe de voir que les yeux des
femmes que ce n'est pas du tout dans nos
principes républicains ni européens
d'ailleurs ça ne fait pas partie de
notre culture et nous avons voulu
dénoncer cela aujourd'hui on montre que
oui les françaises aussi peut-être
peut-être un jour voilées intégralement
et ce n'est pas souhaitable
alli alli ce qu'on est quand on voit ce
qu'a dit cette jeune femme avec en
parlant des des pierres est ce que vous
récupérez pas ça aussi voilà alors
qu'une fois de plus encore la
récupération comme moi je récupère les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
ainsi les races il faut me le dire tout
de suite parce que on va mettre tous les
faits crucifix ils viennent d'articles
et sont sources et et mon expérience
profession ceux de beaucoup de
militantes de nemesis le disent aussi
donc au bout d'un moment il faut arrêter
de se voiler la face un pop affaire john
wood mauvais goût et puis faudrait
peut-être près de répéter le cosim
mettre en avant un réel problème alors
on va passer à la dernière partie
d'émission c'est parti j'aimerais avoir
l'avis du juste debout luxe yachts de
luxe quand il entend ce que dit alice
cordier parce que ça doit 30 pouces à
wes album rendent fou mais j'ai peur et
me fait peur elle est agressée pas moi
mais ça va me fait pas peur elle me fait
peur pourquoi je vous fais peur elle me
fait peur comment
voix l'islam les trucs tu vois c'est
parce que c'est le buzz maintenant si tu
veux faire le buzz faut parler que de
voile d'islam et là tu vas buzz et c'est
ça qu'on l'aurait pas cool chanter comme
ça
oui parce que moi là bas je lui rends
france et quand je vais en vacances en
angleterre je vois plein de choses que
ça n'existe pas en france les deux
policières mais dans le même pays avec
eux je ne sais pas couper la parole en
fait on est dans un débat c'est pas
grave
mettez un voile vous serez plus belle
non c'est elle sur celui de taper votre
femme je crois que vous parlant au
contraire à part les violences
conjugales chez rim simple vous avez
quitté clé dans donc violences contre
leurs évêques - mollo avec maintenant
j'aimerais qu'on reste sur le débat s'il
vous plaît alice faut aller vite vite
fait ce que c'est que de fait vite fait
vite fait qu'est-ce qui se passe une
petite déviation est ce qui est quand
même un sérieux en sièges quand vous
allez chercher les trucs pour voir vos
sources en fait pour devenir si c'est
des vrais source ou pas mais les jeunes
vont mal à la maison elle vit bien vous
inquiétez pas à la maison avait aussi
quand ils arrivent tout le monde vit
bien et pas de trop c'est rien du tout
vous savez même pas c'est quoi
l'histoire vous suivez internet en fait
naître comme ça vous êtes à la recherche
de la gratter chez moi pour les troncs
des wiccans vacances en angleterre en
fait on voit des policiers des gens qui
travaillent avec les turbans avec les
trucs le voile c'est à dire en fait
chacun en france que que le le voit les
ai vus comme tu vois une sorte de comme
si c'étaient les hommes qui qui menace
et les femmes qui les obligeait de
mètres se voit alors que les femmes
c'est elle même qui veulent mettre la
galerie qui veut juste répondre là
dessus a prévenu que tu vois je te dise
pas du tout enfin c'est pas
spécifiquement un problème de l'islam
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'est la
france comment elle s'est façonnée en
fait la france c'est des pros vont
chausser des basques et bretons c'est
les gens qui n'ont aucun rapport les uns
avec les autres au départ il ya un état
central qui va faire une pâte un
amalgame et toi et chez nous il ya jeté
pas je n'ai pas interrompu ni bretons et
corses mais oui mais justement la france
en français il ya un principe d'égalité
et d'unité extrêmement fort dans notre
histoire hors jeu rebondit sur ce que tu
viens de dire qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire là-dessus enfin je vais parce que
c'est très intéressant là la différence
avec l'angleterre par exemple
effectivement en angleterre dans les
pieds en deçà qu'il a raison sur
il est parfaitement et on ne peut y
avoir des femmes voilées policière bien
sûr pourquoi finalement le voile fait
tant de buzz autant de problèmes en
france on vous pose la question est ce l
usure fait sur ce buzz s'est terminée
après vous répondre voilà monsieur
refait sur ce buzz raison très simple et
ça en fait à la bonne raison très simple
c'est quand jamais un onglet va épouser
une pakistanaise
les mariages mixtes sont très importants
chez nous en fait le voile signifie dans
la psychologie français fall a commencé
au galop exogames simplement vous savez
vous êtes le se marie avec des joueurs
est différent la leur de leur origine
qu'ils voulaient ils prennent une femme
ou un mari or de laure nord bassin
origines il n'y a pas deux mais de
préférence ethnique ou de préférence
religieuse c'est juste très important
dans l'histoire de plus tu pourrais
c'est pour ça que le voile signifie la
fin des mauvaises passes et uche vous
toucherait pas à nos femmes enceintes
est venu avec un argument de fou on
verra alors je tiens des arguments une
foule après d'après toi tu es au max les
gens qui tapent sur leurs femmes truc au
max allez au mac smartphones elle est au
max a fait le tour du monde rolex ise
trucks en pis taxe macky sall roulant
4,4 ya pas de trucs comme ça
autour de la femme les gens à peu plus
en plus envie en débat alors si tu
penses que c'est est erroné ton truc
mais partir était parti chercher fouiner
tarata relation nationale 2 juste pour
lui quand on dit que comprenez vous que
leurs proches qui n'est pas assez de
boulot dans les banlieues qu'est-ce que
tu réponds à ça s'il ya des blancs il ya
des blancs et des blancs partout tu sais
très bien déjà comment comment ça se
passe chez nous à rita des blancs il ya
des joueurs sont affichés vous chez nous
chez nous c'est quoi moi déjà je suis de
paris déjà chez nous chez nous ce
scénario nous tous à l'heure c'est la
finesse et la france chez moi je suis
français français jeu français non mais
bien sûr que oui
ah ok j'assure c'est non mais j'ai vu la
présence chez moi chez nous chez nous
j'avais l'impression que ça des exclus
et certaines personnes les mots non chez
nous chez nous voilà vous parler des
banlieues un peu des banlieues des
crèches et bien sûr il ya des noirs moi
j'habite à belleville on habite entre
blancs noirs asiatiques les musulmans
ennemis d'hier est charentais tout le
monde est mélangé sens si vous suivez un
peu mais cela à mon avis vous si vous ne
suivez pas su bien sûr j'ai vu que
j'avais fait un truc avec la police je
vous fais très drôle c'est très bien
très drôle excellent ça c'est les jeux
gamers vous avez une idée de caricatures
il faut que je sois un facho j'sais pas
quoi vous maintenant je viens de
caricature ce nouveau salut est alors
dans votre loge très bien ou très bien
ouais moi je trouve que nous avons
laissé battre j'ai regardé avant
l'émission
c'est plutôt sympa soit là tranquille
mais vous avez regardez vous donne est
bon alice vous attendez quand il dit que
tout le monde vit ensemble pourquoi
habitants son mari on a mis son rouleau
vit ensemble on fait tout ensemble
et vous savez quoi regarder regarder mon
snap regarder tout le monde mon snap ses
brûlures 7,5 dommage je vais vous smap
immo vous allez voir c'est comment c'est
bien pu aller voir comment tout le monde
vit ensemble
en fait c'est que vous qu'est-ce qui se
passe
vendu rien je dis simplement que le
quartier j'ai grandi au 140 rue
ménilmontant c'est à dire c'était une
solution à la cité la pire du quartier
d'accord la pierre de cet endroit tu
poses équivoques
s'il vous plaît à les y aller dit que ça
c'est boboïsée rétablissement des trucs
quartier populaire de venda mon
partenaire au conti 10 à 15 heures et
vous faites comme si oui c'est comme ça
comme ça on sait très bien vous comment
vous êtes vous sûr fait que sur l'islam
le besoin dans les 10 m et l'allemand
alors c'est la mère de famille elle ment
ballon ce qui là même la maman qui a qui
parlent la scala n'y font pas bon
d'avoir des classes à tous les gens qui
s'appellent pierre en tout cas mais t'as
vu un bébé comment tu veux appeler un
bébé pierre il est tout petit normand ça
avait un ton il s'appelle pierre a tenté
alors vas voir cette vidéo
regardez ces combats je déplore le
manque de mixité dans le collège de
quartier les gens ne mettent plus les
enfants dans le même quartier et ce qui
est vraiment dommage présidence j'ai mon
fils qui habite ans il m'a demandé si
pied le prénom de bien exister vraiment
aussi que dans le livre
tellement qu'ils aiment manque de mixité
dans le quartier c'est vraiment
grave je lui dis non puisque pierre
distraitement il ya des gens qui
s'appellent pierre
moi je fais sortir mes enfants mais
c'est vrai que cette question ma machine
alors au juste laurence ça y est moi
j'ai vu le hashtag hier et j'ai vu
surtout la violence en fait on la voit
là la violence c'est à dire qu'on peut
plus parler bas c'est hyper agressif ce
débat je suis désolé on peut pas parler
normalement par exemple du voile il ya
pas de nuances vous êtes pour ou contre
le voile ne pouvez pas dire un boil ça
ne me pose pas de problème par contre et
des jeunes filles qui sont couvertes de
tout le front jusqu'au pied là c'est pas
le même message politique ni religieux
personnes il ya plus de nuances et on en
arrive à des pour ou contre et même
géraldine quand elle dit les gens
veulent vivre entre eux mais entre quoi
pour moi pierre à mettre david ça je
m'en fous complètement
alors il s'arrêter parce qu on est dans
une guerre de tranchées
il est tout à fait désolé où les gens
sont déçus désolé réalité ne sais pas
mais des gens bien aidant il ya des
racailles partout et moi dans le mot
racaille comme je lé dr pour moi c'est
pas liées à l'immigration
donc soit maintenant on pose les choses
sont sur la table et on arrête les
grands délires par exemple on peut être
contre le burqini et je sais que j'ai un
débat très durable et pour le voile et
voyez ce que je veux dire soyez de la
nuance soit on va être dans une bien
vous avez vu la violence parce que là
c'est cette femme était voilée je lui
dire ça je reviens sur le sujet parce
que cette femme était voilée on estime
qu'à l'appel droit de dire qu'il faut
des pierres ben là c'est un vrai sujet
alors david guiraud
non mais moi il ya deux trucs timber les
bioman d'abord moi le premier truc qui
me dérange c'est qu'en fait quand on
parle de non mixité pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va dans les banlieues et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on va pas dans l'est dans les
villes où justement vous avez la moindre
idée vers de ce pays d'asie respecte
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur
une richesse que vous avez vu tout cas
lui de cette femme qu'est ce que vous
comprenez que l'on reproche qu'il n'y
ait pas assez de blancs dans les
banlieues qu'est ce que vous mettez à sa
renommée
l'actif on s'y font que cette question
ça vient des hauts-champs lieu dans
cette question je peux regarder les
séries télé que je vais l'aider mais non
mais je vais juste rapidement mais c'est
magique et on est on non mais c'est pas
ça c'est que c'est que la question
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi les gens ils
sont vous sais pas pourquoi ce qui est
de la faute de ceux qui restent oui ça
c'est très juste
aujourd'hui pourquoi les gens ils
contournent la carte scolaire pourquoi
vous avez des j'en suis aujourd'hui qui
quand ils ont un prénom à consonance
soit maghrébine soit d'origine
subsaharienne
vous avez 40 % de chances en moins
d'avoir un logement achevé on l'a dit on
entasse les gens danser mais madame qui
dit oui
la hausse de l'insécurité dans les
quartiers mais je sais pas dans quel
monde vous vivez vous parlez des
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
ça vous c'est qu'elle explose en 2019 la
sécurité les coûts et les violences sur
les personnes de plus de 15 ans et où à
nouveau les deux sèvres
signalons le set en cédant l'aveyron
c'est dans la lozère c'est dans la
chronique les chiffres internes faut
aimer c'est d'abord de ces jeunes et
loisirs seniors je n'ai pas bien beau
tracé mais si on peut ne pas sa série
lie to me je vous dis juste qu'une chose
je vous dis qu'en fait vous voyez la
violence que quand c'est des noirs et
des inserts foulée qu il ya deux ans
d'augmenter et les mêmes avec des
feuilles de style oh oui c'est
incroyable mais c'est pas s'analyser on
a gagné on regarde mes réseaux sociaux
rahal et moi je suis sûr qu'ils
dénoncent des percées sur vos réseaux
les rations qui ont des mains d'un fan
dans son dessin sur vos réseaux sociaux
reading vous dites que vous luttez pas
tout sur un temps vous dites sur vos
réseaux que vos réseaux sociaux j'ai
regardé vous dites que vous luttez
contre quoi contre la féminisation des
hommes elise est contrôlée ou relais des
pantalons ou je sais pas quoi
c'est ça vos réseaux sociaux vous dites
n'importe quoi ma nasa aura dans
l'oreillette sociaux n'est pas un gage
de vous dire une chose n ya pas que la
faim de l'insécurité mais j'aime banque
privée de lâcher ce que je vais faire
lire une phrase analyse l'insécurité
elle vous gêne pas quand vous souvenez
des petites racailles de génération
identitaire qui met des coups de couteau
sur les gens si jamais vous dire une
chose justement ces américains de voir
les agressions sexuelles et viols
malheureusement dans notre société on a
beaucoup et y en a partout dans les
boîtes de nuit dans les écoles de
commerce dans les quartiers dans les
métros mais je vais vous dire une chose
et cela m'a gentil tout ça c'est dans la
fin ou mai et les explosions de ces de
c2c les gros durs
merci merci
alors stéphane il aime bien s'intéresser
à aux intervenants donc je suis
mademoiselle madame je suis allé voir
votre chaîne youtube et sur la première
vidéo dans votre chaîne youtube à lavau
trois quarts de la vidéo vous dit
pardon je vais remettre les lunettes
nous devons farouchement défendre notre
mâle blanc car ce mâle blanc des autres
que nos pères et seront plus tard nos
fils si si les stades français sont
exactes et que les français de souche
seront en minorité en 2050
l'enjeu tient de la survie pour nos
blancs alors je voudrais juste revenir
sur sable avait dit où vous ne l'avez
pas dit mais bien sur sa maladie
voilà on est d'accord moi je dénonce
tous les jours des personnes blanches
aux siens mais c'est un énorme et je
vois pas ce que monsieur mais pour moi
vous vous êtes hors débat c'est là qu'on
doit vous sortir du plateau parce que
quand on tient des propos comme ça on
est pas objectif est autant arrête
arrête aussi avec lui l'histoire ouais
ouais je suis pour le voile machin ça
donne quoi comme l'image des banlieues
arrête pas de banlieue sud de paris j'ai
pas compris mais alors c'est pareil
arrêt même grande pourquoi je te oui je
te gronde parce que moi moi je tu vois
je vais à marseille où tu as toutes les
plus grandes communautés et toutes les
religions qui sont mélangés et il vit
bien ensemble
il vit bien ensemble parce que non
monsieur monsieur nous on vit bien
ensemble chez nous on vit bien ensemble
et c'est quoi chez nous chez nous c'est
ma france on est d'accord
ouais pourquoi c'est pas chez moi
pourquoi chaque fois jeudi chez nous
vous ne dites rien
mais ce sont les réponses personne n'a
dit que c'était pas subi de nombreuses
attaques et dit chez nous ça vieux
marseille mois sabbatiques j'ai en plus
dure à marseille il avait comme ajouté
c'est vrai ici tu es communauté pourquoi
parce que et la mairie qui vient
d'arriver et là je venais féliciter
alors que c'est pas du tout non c'est
non nous fait un pacte avec les jeunes
avec les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
parce que cel et les cerveaux de demain
donc ils ont fait un pacte où ils vont
leur donner une subvention pour pouvoir
aller faire des études pour voir à fait
aller faire une formation et ils ont un
peu de droits et devoirs et des données
dont on considère que cette femme qui a
dit ça y est elle est donc délirante
faites ce que vous la considérez comme
délirante
non non c'est pas du tout et les rangs
c'est ce que tout le monde d epuis le
début
bah non mais bon pour vous à l'arrivée
mais elle a totalement raison on le sait
que y'a pas moi je me parlait dans celle
où le saumon brûlot du bronze c'est
qu'il ya pas de mixité enfin je veux
dire c'est pas assez un communautarisme
qui ne fait exploser tout le monde en
parle et fait que tout le monde fait
comme si on n'avait jamais vu et pour
revenir je vais quand même vous répondre
parce que c'est trop beau je vais
pouvoir rectifier un petit peu le tir
donc vous sélectionnez déjà ce que je
dis vous enlevez hors du contexte et
puis troisième chose quand je dis le
mâle blanc aujourd'hui on entend tout le
temps parler du mâle blanc 6 dominateur
hétérosexuels qui nous est une femelle
blanche une petite c'est une femelle
blanche où les mouches qui serait
responsable de tomber au champ du débat
là non mais il m'a fait chaud au coeur
du débat
'cela fait une erreur il sort du débat
on va pas répondre avec des jolies c'est
pourquoi vous lui coupez la série mercy
voilà merci merci nous donne la parole
bon est ce que cette dame qui dit voilà
qu'elle a dit est ce que pour toi c'est
ce qu'indique lassana et mahamadou déjà
tellement est-ce que
en fait j'ai déjà des cours on peut pas
tout généralisée tu vas aller dans des
coins en france n'a pas trouvé un barad
tu vas aller dans des cours en france je
me trouvais des blancs mais en petite
minorité
après il ya des endroits et c'est plus
peuplée d'arabes que d'autres des
endroits les plus peuplés de blancs que
d'autres après voilà si à chaque fois tu
t'arrêtes dans chaque quartier
tu vas y à des quartiers tu vas pas
trouvé un noir et des quartiers tu vas
pas trouvé d'ici là ils partiront dans
un quartier ils ont dit pierre il
n'existe pas dans les cités tout dans
les cités je suis un gars et on voulait
tout ça vous connaissez les images
connaissez pas là donc c'est une image
eric ne veut pas mettre son enfant dans
l'école de la république parce qu'il
n'ya pas de mixité et elle elle veut
connaître l'école comme elle l'a connue
elle quand elle était petite
avec des journaux sur tous les horizons
de tous les films on met tous dans
dans le même endroit chaque fois je sais
pas qui ils
je sais pas qui ils trient je suis
médecin pas qu'ici nous nous c'est nous
et il sait il que vous les arrêter trop
sur les nous concerne on n'est pas dans
ça en tout cas moi je comprends pas trop
pourquoi on faire raciste se
compromettre et mis en garde car je sais
pas qui viennent ici sa défaite il ya
des gens pendant un premier temps il y
avait des centaines de milliers de
maghrébins qui ont combattu pour la
france pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et leurs descendants ils sont
toujours en france il s'est jeté dans
les eaux opaques au près serré le dire
un mot en fait enfin ce qu'est la france
on le sait que quand il ya des
situations vraiment tragique
je veux rappeler la mémoire de quelqu'un
qui s'appelle manoukian d'accord missak
manouchian c'était un arménien il a pris
les armes contre l'occupant allemand
il a été fusillé au mont valérien ce
type a les moins de 30 ans il attendait
un sa femme attendait un enfant il avait
fait un accord qu'est ce qu'il a dit il
a écrit en signant michel manoukian
soldats de la france libre voilà c'est
pour ça c'est ça la similarité contre le
racisme et la france et qu'ils méritent
notre respect qu'ils y ont aidé à vis de
moi je vous dis à eric tu es moi ça me
gêne aujourd'hui en 2021 d'avoir
derrière moi comprenez vous que l'on
reproche premiers pas assez de blu ray
c'est un débat que j'aurais jamais cru
faire y as aimé cda glisserait ya 15 ans
eh bien non c'est complètement délirant
quand depuis quand moi jamais je dis il
le sait une fois branché habité de la
audi daou il y avait on parlait pas de
blanc de noir de donc pas en son absence
tout est bel et bien un endroit
aujourd'hui maman vers le monde doit
servir mais tout c'est incroyable il a
aujourd'hui regardé le débat c'est
incroyable pas assez de blancs dans ma
tête j'ai mais j'ai jamais pensé moi
blanc noir truc on pense pas ça va moyen
qu à la télé que je vois ce genre de
trucs oui mais ça peut rien n'y a pas de
ria pas ce genre de débat on sera
habitent tous ensemble on veut qu'à ce
qu'elle a dit
adam donc de rien mais on attend
aujourd'hui c'est au matin on a toujours
subi ce petit truc mais aussi quand même
en france quand on est en france ils
disent retournez chez vous je les ai
déjà entendu ça quand je vais en tunisie
aussi retourne chez toi en france ça
veut dire manger pas de chez moi
tu comprends ça veut dire des deux côtés
ont subi des petits trucs comme ça mais
m'a franchement ça me tiens ça me tient
pas à coeur ça me touche pas ça me vexe
pas et moi je sais dehors c'est quoi la
vraie réalité on cohabite tous ensemble
tous ensemble tous ensemble juifs
musulmans chrétiens arabes chinois noir
blanc jus tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde quand vous annoncer sa
liste est ce que vous y croyez à ce
qu'on dit là avec british open regard
branche toi / snap par sinar mas de
sauvegarde branche toi sur ça alors il
est temps pour toi mon ami pour moi je
demande a ajouté mme m'intéresse pas
comme ça tu vas sortir du cese des trucs
tous indiqué juste nappe depuis le début
c'est que ça mais tu te parle comme ça
je vais te montrer je vais te montrer je
me vois les saint-louis d'accord alors
excusez ma laissant pas laisser ceux qui
croient ça quand on dit quand on dit
pour moi voilà quand je suis moi je suis
montré aux 8,2 rien qu'on puisse faire
un ce genre de débats aujourd'hui
guillaume aussi ils étaient 1 parce que
là tu en sais rien c'est incroyable
c'est pire cyril que ça sert si
quelqu'un avait dit ça bah oui qui
n'était pas issu de l'immigration
sa tombe est saturé en dix ans il sera
le droit qu'à sabratha par les prix
n'étaient rien calories un peu délirant
de l'extrême droite c'est à dire c'est
le l'écrivain renaud camus qui appelait
ça le grand remplacement
je pense que cette théorie franchement
et délirante pourquoi les délirantes
parce qu'en fait ce que dit cette femme
est ce que montre cette femme c'est la
réalité du pays
c'est un petit remplacement et la
question c'est pourquoi il ya un petit
remplacement et qu'est ce que c'est ce
mécanisme en réalité l'immigration ça
peut être très positif pour un pays
d'immigration
quelles que soient les origines des
immigrés il faut simplement qu'elle au
moins quelques conditions que soient
réunies la première condition ce qu'il
faut qu'une croissance économique forte
parce que s'il n'y a pas de croissance
économique et du chômage important ce
qui est le cas la france paie 30 40 ans
et qu'on fait venir des gens qu'ils vont
non seulement pas trouvé de travail et
de voir se dérouler sur fond pour faire
d'autres trucs et deuxièmement quand ils
viennent
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire concurrence
à des gens qui sont déjà au chômage à
waimes et donc il faut vraiment être de
droite pour soutenir les migrations à
brno
cette forme qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle
veut que ses enfants d'ailleurs le truc
est découpée sur les réseaux sociaux
malheureusement faire une sauce au comme
ça c'est très réducteur elle dit moi
j'ai mis mes enfants elle lui donner
l'un de mes deux enfants j'ai mis dans
le privé elle parle pas de voir pourquoi
elle a fait ça parce qu'elle sait que
ces enfants l'avenir de ses enfants
c'est de s'assimiler en fait à la france
c'est une évidence je vais dans l'ue
immigrés c'est toujours très compliqué
c'est quitter un pays c'est très jeune
en tête ils migrent sci les gens ne font
pas ça volontairement il ya que les gens
qui les font venir fêter ça va vous des
regrets arrêté par la vidéo des noirs et
des arabes de ce pays que comme système
uniquement des immigrés vers deux mois
sont là que vous qui lisez des
programmes ou sage et shalva dans
l'année noire il ya dix ans la limite 1
nul a été lancée depuis 1800 depuis
l'indépendance des deux depuis la
reconnaissance des dom-tom d'accord ces
gens-là leurs enfants ça fait cent
cinquante ans qu'on les parcs dans des
ghettos
c'est ça la réalité et donc la question
qu'on se pose c'est pas juste uniquement
l'immigration de ceux qui viennent
d'arriver
c'est comment on traite dignement les
gens comment est ce qu'on fait qu'on ait
des débats un peu serein et digne pour
se dire que c'est pas normal que moi
dans mon département où j'ai vécu 29 ans
donc je sais un peu de quoi enfin même
si je pas quelqu'un des quartiers mais
mes deux je sais pas vraiment inquiet
car en seine saint denis un enfant qui
va à l'école
d'accord il ya tellement il ya tellement
peu de preuves pour remplacer les profs
absents qui perd un an de scolarité donc
forcément les gens qui ont les moyens
baissent et leurs enfants donc ils
contournent la carte soleil il n'ya pas
leur en vouloir
mais c'est ça pour moi pour moi la
france c'est comme l'équipe de france
c'est ça la france des noirs des arabes
ont un manque benzema didier deschamps
il faut se voir le maillot un maillot
commun est là mais quand vois griezmann
qui dansent avec plus bas ça parlait à
l'issue une fois tranquillement a dit
qu'est ce que vient de dire là au lieu
que si vous vous dites sur l'équipe de
france laquelle a été racheté en grande
partie par le qatar donc six et sept
types de français
en plus de bien dexedrine lui maintenant
par l'équipe de france répondra ville
blanche c'est bien ça parle sur snap sud
on parlait tout le temps vous bien c'est
bastos et de ministre des aînés mais
c'est ce qu'ont fait naître
s'il vous plaît alice alice laquelle je
vous ai posé ses l'équivoque sur rendez
vous alors notre échiquier tu me des
pubs decaux a pu s'échouer qui jeune
star internationale avec les lib dems
qui couronnent nous saluons madame stars
internationales et belleville est mon
ami mais bon comment il alors on peut
venir de belleville est alors j'adore
belleville et j'habite au 54 basée à
l'habitat 56
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on écoute alice gentiment
annoncé sera l'équipe de france parce
que l'équipe de france c'est vrai que
voilà il ya une mixité de l'équipe de
france et il a pris le bon exemple dans
quel but à sa souplesse bas et enfin je
pense pas qu'on puisse comparer l'équipe
de france et ce qui se passe notamment
dans certains lots risque ça prouve ce
que disait plus long séjour
ça rejoint ce que disait guillaume alors
comment il ya huit ans comment après je
pense que je crois que ce qui se
ressemble s'assemble aussi un phénomène
de communautarisation qui est aussi
normal les gens se fréquente entre eux
et avec ce qu'ils ont en commun
et moi je pense que malheureusement on a
aussi alors on parle beaucoup de racisme
anti blanc je sais pas si c'est un
racisme anti blanc de 6 un racisme anti
français
je suis désolé dans certaines cités dans
certaines zones dites rouges
il ya aussi un phénomène dans
l'impression qu'il ya une volonté de non
assimilation et la gêne et la femme là
qui parler pour moi c'est un ovni mais
ça vous n'avez jamais madame est donc
dans votre organisation existe des
indications en comble c'est que la vie
prôné le fait qu' il qu'on protège le
mâle blanc nous en fait vous même vous
voulez créer cette maman bonne
organisation des femmes mais non merci
j'ai dépanné la suspecte alors si vous
verrez je vous en prie à 36%
non il m'a 64% gilbert dette c'est
invraisemblable ce que dit madame
en fait vous expliquer que cette mère de
famille que les gens qui vivent dans les
banlieues il vole le communautarisme
mais ils ne veulent pas ça ils le
subissent
parce qu'on l'ait pas dans des ghettos
mais réveillez vous madame aubry
choisissent pas d'être là où ils sont
ils choisissent pas d'être ghettoïser
qui le subissent à rien des raisons
économiques
on a entendu là-dessus mais je vais vous
dire moi je trouve ce qu'a déclaré cette
dame c'est un message d'espoir et c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le voir elle
souhaite la mixité sociale ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire un idéal de société
c'est à dire une cohésion nationale et
surtout une égalité des chances quand on
est tous ensemble pour ça je dis bravo à
cette femme d'avoir dit ça c'est très
important mais il faut voir il faut voir
le message d'espoir pas d'histoire pas
de conneries c'est moi je suis choqué
par la récupération politique autour de
cette image notamment de la part de
l'extrême droite on a une femme
musulmane qui déplore le manque de
mixité qui aimerait que ses enfants
jouer avec d'autres enfants issus
d'autres cultures qui pratiquent
d'autres religions et elle se fait
défoncer sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment par l'extrême droite chez lui
un tweet de jean médias s'il n'y a plus
de pierre c'est parce qu'ils ont été
lynchées à mort par des jeunes d'un
quartier comme le vôtre je prends ça
honteux et c'est dommage qu'ils
comprennent pas de l'objectif qui est
celui du vivre ensemble et pas de la
haine des ans vers l'est une minute
c'est très intéressant dans ce débat
c'est qui en fait un déni c'est là
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette
dame il faut écouter ce qu'elle dit elle
ne dit pas je veux plus de riches dans
mon quartier
elle dit je ne sais même pas mes enfants
ne savent même pas que pierre est un
prénom et ils veulent voir des pierres
en fait c'est la question qui est
refoulé c'est la question de la
simulation et la simulation c'est
contrairement à ce qu'on pense et pas
forcer les gens soient en retirer les
voiles soit devenir trans à des forces
pas du tout la destination de ces
suspects sur le fait que les gens qui
sont ces deux là c'est pas de
l'assimilation finir à devenir français
comment ça nous faut bien pour les
enfants assimilent chaque fois qu'il ya
une majorité de fondement
vive la france et puis on l'a mixé en
lait
on est là aujourd'hui c'est terminé
il parle d'assimilation mais comment on
fait quand on sait que dans les
quartiers
un jeune sur trois entre 16 et 25 ans et
au chômage comment vous assumez les